and did you have to wear prosthetics for
this i did because i because i was like
you know a haggard ghostly sunken
version of michael moriarty basically
you want to see it there's a picture oh
is there really let me see that that's
me how did you find that because
the weber net is amazing right yeah now
how was that that was that looks like
that was probably your first real big
prosthetic piece right for a movie for
me i had done them for commercials
before that yeah so but how'd that feel
going into that did you feel
do you how many hours did that take no
it just takes out it almost takes hours
and and hours yeah yeah yeah and you
just because you you know what do you do
during that time
read
no no you can't you listen to music
music yes uh tell stories with your
makeup artist they become your best
friends they always deal with them all
day always too it's like it's like being
in a barber's chair or or being at a uh
your bartender right yeah
that's so true they're your therapist
they're therapists yeah yeah
so uh there's all that i might even if
it's if i'm in a chair and they're just
working on my front side i can maybe
doze off maybe if they tilt me back a
little bit uh you like dozing off oh i
do especially with you know if you have
a 3 a.m call time for a long makeup job
and yeah you'll i i do many jobs sleep
deprived so right that's part of the
deal and makeups can be anywhere from
two hours like on star trek discovery
they've got these pre-made pre-painted
uh prosthetic pieces that get glued onto
me and blended in saru suru
the human characters on star trek are in
as much makeup as much time in the
makeup and hair
trailers as i am
so uh so it's not so bad but then you
you know if you're doing a head to toe
creature like like abe sapien from the
first hellboy movie uh they got it it
was seven hours a day they got it down
to five hours a day for hellboy to the
golden army
so down to five hours a day is it a
daunting thing to go to bed at night and
go i have to wake up and be seven hours
and make up oh yeah yeah yeah do you get
anxiety the word tell me about that
[Music]
yeah no i wouldn't say anxiety but i do
i i have spent mo a lot of my career
dreading going to work you know just
because it's like oh i gotta go through
this even though even if it's a project
i love and i and that's the end if the
end result is a product we'll be proud
of then i can go through the hell that
it takes to make it because i did come
up with a
a few years ago i'm very proud of it's
called and it is uh spirit pain is
temporary film is forever
temporary film is for and that's so true
that has been my matter how you're
feeling this is going to be forever so
great your best okay
[Music]
wow
you have to think though
all those hours in the makeup trailer
you get a little upset a little unnerved
a little irritable a little bit
seriously no no no you're you're you're
just you're just a different specimen
different